what's up y'all welcome to riffin with
Griffin I just want to
say have a wonderful happy New Year I'm
excited for 2024 as you know I'm having
a baby and it was a great year 2023 a
lot of great things happened but hey
look I'm going to have some changes to
the podcast coming in
2024 I'm going to be for sure putting
content on my patreon so make sure you
guys check that out YouTube members
twitch subscribers patreon members you
all gonna get special content coming in
2024 in January so just want to say
thank you for
always listening and watching and all
your great support I truly appreciate
you all you
[Music]
know anyways thanks a lot and I will see
you next year